well joining us now is chaparral course
sandy uh comedienne and friend of the
radcliffe family hi it's good to see you
how are they have you spoken to them
oh i'm leaving them alone for a little
bit i think
we've been um
so um
all my family and our friends and
supporters of them have been so wrapped
up in their their story that i've been
waiting
i said to richard a while back that i'm
waiting for the time where i leave you
alone
um because i think that's what they they
need at the moment just to oh i don't
know and i i can't wait to speak to them
but i think right now i'm going to give
them um
a couple of days to
just stare at each other
yeah reacquaint each other and richard
to make that promised cup of tea that we
were hearing so much about yesterday um
this is great picture of the them being
reunited did you see the moving pictures
of them being reunited at the airport
this morning i mean it was uh it was
beyond i mean this is it's like a dream
i can't articulate what it feels like
right now um it's been a dream
particularly as it's iranian new year um
starting on sunday monday for 13 days
and that's around the time when she was
taken so as the new year approached
again i felt bleak
i felt bleak and i didn't even i just
thought i should call richard but i just
thought it's so sad if there's no news
and then when it happened
oh i phoned my brother in rome yesterday
poor man he still can't talk to me i
don't think he stopped crying because my
brother was the first person
to tell me about all this because
nazanin was a facebook friend of his
and he was saying to me that i've met
this guy richard and his wife in iran's
been taken away and at the time this is
back in
2016. i said pave it's iran they do this
all the time she'll be out in a couple
of weeks don't upset yourself and that
that was my thinking because
you know we iranians are
it's not new this out this kind of
outrageousness from the iranian
government
um i mean it's why i live in london and
why i'm in exile but um
and as time went on it was clear that
this wasn't one of those situations
where they were
just playing a little game with with
someone this went on and on and then i
met richard um so this is yeah this
would have been about six years ago now
and uh i just remember
him saying to me when i said to him you
can speak to your daughter on zoom on on
not zoom back then what was it face
facebook
facetime face time
yeah and he said well and he's such a
calm man
and he said
well um she's forgetting her english and
that really that
that simple little fact really broke me
because you know to to know that your
child has forgotten the language that
they
that you loved them in and um
that
there were thousands of little
moments like that throughout the six
years that just chip away at your heart
and now they're back together again
um i just uh
i can't quite put into words what it is
it feels like life life can go on now
for
for everyone because until nazney was
home i think anyone who who knew them or
campaigned for them and it was very
empathetic it was just this
dark backdrop and just seeing him just
watching now her coming down those
stairs with their new shirt and oh i'm
so happy for them all
and just look passionate a lot aren't
you you iranians
come out um
talk to me if you would please about
we've been hearing a lot about the new
leader and how
it was because of his election that this
potential deal has been uh made possible
uh what's your view on him
i think that how this deal was made
possible and why now and all of that
will
will be discussed in
weeks and actually probably years to
come i don't think we we can know
completely
why this happened now or it was
because of a changing regime or this and
that and it all seems so um
complicated and uh frankly a lot of it
is so insidious to look at that i think
that's um
right now i just want to sit with we are
very passionate this iranians love two
things passions and tea
so
um
and all of the analysis of it i think is
going to be very interesting and i am
being very positive about everyone right
now but just you wait kay just sure i'll
have some things to say about certain
people
when everyone's up there
you come and tell us whenever you fancy
obviously it's a breakfast show so keep
it you know more or less down the middle
um
as you were saying it's the persian new
year uh this weekend um i suppose that
would be quite a good time for you to
get together with the family wouldn't it
it is yes it's a rainy new year i'm
working as ever on a rainy new year
there we are but it is a time for family
and it's a time where we go
visit everyone so i'd like to wish
all of your viewers who are iranian no
ruse p rules
well what does that mean
it means happy new year and
pirus means jubilation and victory
oh okay i'm going to practice that tell
me again do it slowly no rules
means new day new year
p rules
is a beautiful word it's a mixture of
sort of success and uh
victory
yeah okay uh fantastic and
your um excitement about it all is
absolutely intoxicating i i honestly
it's it's such a wonderful day isn't it
for the family i'm like don't ring
richard re leave him alone
don't wake them
up exactly well when you do see them do
pass on our congratulations as well
we've you know we've uh felt it with uh
richards as he's gone along with his
oh those twice i think he was on hunger
strike wasn't he and um you know he's
he's battled on he is without question
he's set the bar so high for husbands um
everywhere so um
i had a conversation with my partner
last night so if it happened to me how
long would you campaign for and when
this is a weird little argument but
yeah i'm sure lots of families are
having those discussions as well thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us on the programme this morning it's
been great to talk to you thank you